es ist absolut erschreckend und ein
warnruf wir essen unmengen nico plastik
eine britische forschungsgruppe hat per
zufall die menge heraus gefunden und sie
ist exorbitant wirklicher wahnsinn
demnach essen wir jedes jahr 70.000
micro plastikteilchen eine wirklich
irrwitzige menge und wahrscheinlich ist
es noch viel mehr das unglaubliche
problem mit dem mikro plastik und warum
es dramatische ausmaße annimmt jetzt den
klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen
ja es ist ja eine wirklich dramatische
entwicklung mit dem mikro plastik es ist
in so vielen produkten wie zahnpasta
oder kosmetikartikel und es wird immer
mehr durch das zerreiben des
plastikmülls erzeugt und das absolut
erschreckende im meer ist es
verschwunden
ein absolutes horror-szenario laut dem
fünfjahres institut schwimmen in den
weltmeeren 269.000 tonnen plastikmüll
das sind rund 38.500 müllwagen ladung
und das ist nur der müll der oben
schwimmt das ist nicht nur eine ziemlich
schlimme sauerei sondern auch eine üble
verseuchung der umwelt viele denken bei
plastikmüll an hässliche tüten flaschen
styropor folien und so weiter das ist
schön und auch daran sterben tiere die
sich darin verfangen und qualvoll
verhungern und oder ersticken aber das
ist nur die spitze des eisbergs das team
um den forscher marcus ericsson hat um
die müllmenge genauer zu bestimmen die
daten aus 24 untersuchungen mit 1500
sammlungen und beobachtungen zusammen
getragen und ist so auf diese hohe menge
gekommen dabei ist die anzahl der tonnen
noch nicht mal so hoch wenn man die zahl
der plastikteilchen hört es sind fünf
millionen teilchen sprich 5000
milliarden plastikteilchen die in
unseren ozean schwimmen eine absolut
erschreckende zahl viel schlimmer ist
aber das was die forscher nicht gefunden
haben die menge der plastikteile mit der
größe eines sandkorn zwar 100 mal
geringer als vermutet und das ist ein
ganz schlechtes zeichen
es gibt zwei möglichkeiten die zeichen
gelangen in tiefere wasserschichten oder
und das ist ein wirkliches
horrorszenario werden in riesigen mengen
von fischen gegessen und das ist ja auch
inzwischen x-fach bestätigt worden
das mikro plastik ist über alle mehr
aber nicht nur da
das hat jetzt eine neue studie
herausgefunden in jeder mahlzeit die wir
zu uns nehmen sind rund
100 mikro plastikteilchen aber woher
kommen die teilchen und jetzt wird es
wirklich spooky sie kommen aus der luft
bot das forschungsteam um ted henry von
der harry potter university in edinburgh
untersuchte dazu wieviel micro
plastikteilchen während einer mahlzeit
aus der luft auf dem teller landen dazu
wurden petrischalen mit einer klebrigen
substanz aufgestellt um die menge
während einer mahlzeit zu zählen die aus
der luft auf dem teller landet es waren
und jetzt festhalten 100 und damit sind
das 70.000 im jahr pro mensch zitat wer
bisher annahmen dass der anteil an
plastik fasern in meeresfrüchten höher
sei als im durchschnittlichen hausstaub
für den sind diese ergebnisse
überraschend wir wissen nicht woher all
diese fasern genau kommen außer dass er
sich im haus befinden so der
studienautor ted henry hier mal eine
aufnahme aus meiner wohnung so viel
staub sammelt sich hier in berlin in
rund fünf tagen und offenbar ist das
nicht nur staub sondern auch eine menge
micro plastik absolut erschreckend und
die gesundheitlichen konsequenzen sind
heute noch gar nicht abzusehen an den
plastikteilchen haften chemikalien und
mikroben an die sich dann im menschen
anreichern beziehungsweise so überhaupt
erst in uns gelangt wenn er als erstes
neues zum thema micro plastik und zu
allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann
endet meine telefonnummer hierbei
whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor
allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich
garantiert und zur begrüßung gibt es
noch ein kleines geschenk einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo
mit der genauen blogger vergessen hier
geht es weiter mit
dafür auch draufklicken wir essen
classic da ging es nur um die
verschmutzung in den meeren ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran